je suis un zombie cette maladie ne veux
pas me laisser en paix mais on s'en bat
les couilles parce qu'aujourd'hui les
amis on va vivre une nouvelle histoire
d'amour et oui vous vous souvenez il ya
quelques années qu'on a joué à emilie is
the way c'était un simulateur de msn ou
tu parles est une fille qui s'appelait
emilie et tu année après année je voyais
la relation qui s'établissait entre toi
et sept filles et c'était hyper
frustrant parce que c'était clairement
la meuf de ta vie mais tu passais à côté
bao chau et patrice soit patrice le 2
vient de sortir peut-être que cette fois
il arrive à sortir avec la meuf de sa
vie c'est ce qu'on lui souhaite
ok chapitre 1 était 2006 et mélisse et
qui me dit ma mère direct c'est tout le
monde n'importe quelle fille n'importe
quel mec n'importe quelle personne que
chacun a déjà aimé au comment sur un peu
d'émotion c'est ça mais mu ça m'émeut
pense que je constate c'est que c'est le
même chat de merde un camion ils ont pas
passé à facebook ou quoi on va s'appeler
philippe les filles est là dans la
mecque s'appelle philippe et first name
on va s'appeler filipos les pièces d'or
les mecs qui ont fini pose comme une
famille on est en train d'établir notre
profil plutôt chamillionaire ou plutôt
arctic monkeys ou against me plutôt
arctic monkeys
ok c'est parti liot filipos et déjà
philippe rey se présente il m'appelle
philippe se plaît ok les jo après la
confiance yoav l'ena hockey qui était vu
line the chill j'allais mettre du vernis
sur les ongles
je n'arrive pas à me décider sur la
couleur attentats parce que si c'est pas
emilie on s'en bat les couilles nous on
veut juste par là emilie noir cyan où je
crois en toi je crois en toi bien sûr se
sentira soutenu et on gagne des points
alors si vous avez des bus sur une fine
appliquée jamais ce que j'ai dit à mes
vidéos
c'est le pire tout cas faire agresser un
vrai problème en parlant de couleur j'ai
bientôt de vos projets ouais ça m'a pris
du temps
je sais pas de quoi ils parlent alors
comment s'est passé ton était bien ça va
bien sétif pas dire que ternir me faut
pas dire que c'est ouf non plus grosse
mais on se met dans la partie notre un
peu de la réponse tu vois encore une
fois nous suivait jamais ce conseil cool
qu'est ce que tu as fait des jeux vidéo
je suis sorti avec mes amis où j'ai fait
la romance h sortie que mes administrés
bien on est un jeune basique on est
classique oh cool cool
j'arrive pas à quoi qu'on retourne en
cours dans un mois l'école c'est nul
ouais l'école c'est sympa j'ai à dire
tourner bon on va dire que l'école c'est
normal voilà non mais là on est tout
retourné d'autres mais d'un coup on va
se dissocier mon pote comme le film des
suricates et tu vas voir ils vont être
choqués en face ouais ça peut l'être
comme notre histoire en cours de l'année
dernière
maintenant fausse alerte [ __ ] j'ai mal
traduit comme notre classe d'histoire
l'année dernière oh [ __ ] j'suis trop
chaud la pompe ce qu'ils doivent ou au
mouillage voix joies de l'amour là il y
en a pas du tout je dis ouais cette
classe était cool
ah mais c'est un peu des réponses fermes
et que je fais je fait que valider ce
qu'elles disent en ouvrir deux portes
c'est un peu nul j'ai un peu une merde
j'ai peut-être été draguée des femmes à
tout jamais tu devrais sortir avec moi
et mes amis des fois carrément carrément
là on répond carrément est-ce que tu as
détruit que prévu pour le reste des
vacances on va dire sortir plus comme ça
on lui tend une perche mon pote comme as
une règle 30 cm du temps on veut qu'elle
la trappe qu'elle nous réponde viens
viens avec moi pas de souci et qu'elle
en fasse une équerre a pris comme celle
là c'est énorme ce que je dis moi et mes
amis on va faire une voire fait tour
samedi c'est un festival de musique punk
rock c'est quoi ton type de musique
préféré le punk rock comme toi ôté mon
nouveau meilleur ami
egan corps non mais je pense qu'en vrai
c'est pas elle la fille qu'on veut c'est
chaud laissez moi me consoler en me
disant ça mec je sais pas où sont mes
amis ils étaient supposés venir me
chercher il ya trente minutes
est-ce que vous n'êtes voir cette porte
s'ouvrir cette perche se teindre tout
est sous contrôle faites moi confiance
ils sont probablement morts moi
j'attends le second degré ça fait
beaucoup rire le problème c'est que si
elles n'ont on est mort lol tu as
sûrement raison on était supposé aller
chez un ami et faire la fête et me
laisser seul comme ça mais après c'est
un peu votre colle mais peut-être
qu'elle va nous proposer de venir du
coup tu en fais pas j'ai mon téléphone
[Musique]
cette vidéo c'est un coup de couteau
permanent dans le coeur quoi je devrais
probablement commencer à rassembler mes
affaires franchement tu peux me glisser
dedans dans ton sac vite fait personne
là on va juste lui dire tu reviens pas
ce soir je sais pas je vais peut-être
dormir là bas on va voir enfin djamel un
film tu veut m'aider à le choisir
non mais attends mais la mecque s'est
plu à fresnes zone la mecque la place et
l'armée l'armée de l'amitié qua non mais
vraiment on lui tend des perches monga
monumental jamais elle nous propose de
venir et par coûte choisir le film
devant lequel va emballer son mec là pas
de problème un [ __ ] on va sur les
dents le pire film avec le film vraiment
c'est pas propice à embrasser quelqu'un
genre le livre de la jungle monga
destination finale 3 ou the descent
attend mais très bonne idée ça des trucs
gore maintenant c'est pareil [ __ ] on
est baisé ou msn c'est trop horreur donc
on va dire final de ce match
quel type de film tu adores action
comédie horreur moi j'adore le voir elle
a proposé deux trucs d'horreur ça peut
être pas mal de dire ouais mais non elle
va encore plus l'être dans la case au
meilleur ami tu pense comme moi or à moi
aussi se méfie préféré on devrait
surmonter un ensemble un de ces 4 ou un
de ces deux mêmes tout de suite allé par
contre je crie allez c'est marrant par
contre je crie faut la faire rire un
petit peu comme on dit femme qui rit
égale femme qui te dit tu es mon
meilleur ami ar oui les amis et je vais
en avoir un texto me dis pas que tu es
amis sont là ils seront bientôt la
[ __ ] non il nous échappe elle nous
file entre les doigts elle passe entre
les mailles du filet je veux dire ils
sont pas morts c'est marrant tous ces
gens ont fait genre qu'on s'en bat les
coups qu'il en soit et sans doute futur
vers santa sangre fille pour faire genre
que tu t'en bats les couilles
alors qu'en vrai ça te casses les
couilles bon il nous a pas répondu et on
a eu un message de merdes 35 c'est pas
emilienne justement comment ça va je
chill
oh [ __ ] il va nous a parlé ouais ils
sont pas morts ils faisaient ils sortent
à parce que steve était allé acheter de
l'alcool qui est steve on va juste hier
et je le connais c'est mieux ça passe
bien ça passe mieux que qui est steve
opérations croisées la mrc anciens qui
nous a redit un truc je tu ils aussi
tu as fait un truc cool aujourd'hui je
suis sorti avec mes amis immense pitot
immense 8 ou faut bien faire genre qu'on
a une vie et cadeaux de suite qui tourne
autour de nous au quai du coup c'est eva
qui nous a répondu
steve myers il a eu son diplôme de
l'année dernière il a seulement 20 ans
mais il a une fausse carte d'identité
ouais parce que l'alcool c'est
l'internât aux états unis du coup ces
merdes 105 et ne répond cool qu'est ce
que vous avez fait ah oui c'est vrai
parce que je lui avais dit qu'on était
sorti et que vous avez [ __ ] la
conversation croisés elle et elle est
terrible moi j'ai passé la matinée à
jouer aux jeux vidéo cool on aurait dû
jouer ensemble c'est très bien sa petite
réponse bien ça montre que nous aussi on
joue aux jeux vidéo
on est bien on est bien on est bien j'ai
joué aux sims 2 je suis accro à ce jeu
ah ah ouais très bon choix on lui répond
juste très bon choix
sorgues ont fait pas le mytho elle se
doute que si on lui dit à moi aussi je
suis fan elle va faire ok eva [ __ ]
lacoste se croisent et ça me pète le
crâne là j'ai besoin de trucs à faire à
on va lui dire on pourrait faire un truc
j'aime bien pas trop montrer qu'on a
intéressé tu vois si je dis non pas bien
sûr que tu vois toi qui as pécho 600
filles alors que t'es con 6e 1 ouais on
pourrait en ressortir juste nous deux
ouais ouais juste nous baser la nage en
eau dans là je rentre dedans bien mais
non mais non il avait écrit way juste ou
deux il a effacé pour marquer comme tu
veux mais non mais juste de samba et en
plus on aime tous les deux les films
d'horreur 11 ans lequel prochain oh là
là là là ok c'est fini à queva j'espère
juste que ce week-end il va rien se
passer avec ses amis de merde [ __ ]
c'est bon on peut se concentrer sur la
création et qui verse 35
restons amis hockey une ficelle c'est la
double dans l'espace de vingt minutes de
jeu on va répondre
on verra en mode saas objets statues
envie qu'on reste juste amis es ce que
tu connais le groupe qui s'appelle snow
patrol
ah oui la chanson chasing cars énorme
j'aimerais tellement le voir en concert
mais bon il n'y a jamais eu aucun groupe
qui vient jouer par ici totalement vrai
tout ce qu'on a c'est genre le warped
tour abbas et le truc où il ya où il ya
et va actuellement en train de pêcher un
autre mec
ah ouais c'est le festival de musique
punk c'est ça tu connais quelqu'un qui
est allé ne jamais mentir il ne faut
jamais mentir ouais des amis samu tout
est finalement tel mis à jour tabio
arctic monkeys moi aussi sont dans mes
infos au docteur la personne préféré
maintenant c'est pas mal ça on est bien
là là on est bien là jeff veux qu'on
sorte ensemble avec ses amis ce week-end
mais j'ai vraiment pas envie peut-être
qu une fille te dis ça je sais pas
pourquoi mais c'est ça sent bon ça sent
la rose d'or dans ta chambre tu es là tu
es à mais quelle perte colossale cupid
des faux répond c'est très bien ça
stupide jeff et c'est stupide z'amis où
là c'est un peu violent à ils sont pas
si terribles mais sortir et que ça veut
juste dire trenet et être bourré ans est
nul
quand j'ai répondu direct aux nuls du
coup j'ai paniqué j'ai dit que j'avais
déjà un truc de prévu mais tu n'as rien
de prévu on lui répond et là les amis on
touche au but
aucun n'aura faut que je trouve un truc
à faire demain on n'a rien prévu assez
bien ça j'aime bien cette réponse là
c'est la cata il a dit on a rien de
prévu on pourrait jouer à des jeux vidéo
tout leno s'est améliorée big jouent aux
jeux vidéo oui pourquoi pas est ce qu'on
devrait inviter d'autres gens non tu ne
refaites pas la même erreur que tout à
l'heure philippot je te le dis ils
corrigent et y mais je m'en fous comme
tu veux il me weiler philippe au sein il
me fait l'art peu importe façon on
n'aime pas les mêmes jeux donc peut-être
qu'on devrait inviter d'autres gens et
faire autre chose que jouer aux jeux
vidéo c'est un philippe hoste a leaké
legay mon gars tu es tu t'es nul répondu
ok pourquoi pas qu il se fait tard ouais
bon c'est fini quoi on doit elle va
dormir elle va dormir on n'en parle plus
elle a dès qu on déco aussi au [ __ ]
les amis c'est la fin de cette première
vidéo sur evil is the way 2 [ __ ] mais
qui sent le triangle amoureux chez lula
qui arrive tu ça ou pas machin est
amoureuse de nous on est amoureux des
va-et-vient est amoureuse de machin
n'importe quoi je sens qu'il va falloir
gérer parce que sinon mais qu'on va se
prendre une
double fredzone déjà là on s'est pris
une double fredzone à l'heure actuelle
maintenant la plage peut déjeuner en
travers de la gorge bon gars le stabilo
boss et par les amis je pense qu'on aura
encore une deux ou trois vidéos sur ce
jeu je trouve qu'il est trop bien fait
au niveau du scénario les dialogues sont
hyper réaliste et et [ __ ] on a envie
de sortir avec eux avec l'une des deux
filles quoi là on a deux profils
différents l'uncam faire des tournées
avec ses potes et se bourrer la gueule
l'autre qui est plutôt introverti qui
jouent aux jeux vidéo qui aime pas trop
sortir et boire je me demande vers qui
on va aller et comment ça va se passer
et je suis sûr que les deux filles là
vont se parler entre elles enfin bref je
me fais des films dont 28 ans a pas du
tout aller jouer date les deux
prochaines vidéos portez vous bien
pourquoi je sais tous trois nous on sait
pas au revoir
[Musique]